[Music]
[Applause]
yes paulie
uh tim legler our guest who's coming up
next yes former nba sharpshooter yes um
he shot 52 twice
for the season from three okay which has
to be some of the greatest of all time
but here's a tim legler trivia question
okay tim legler is known as a guy who
came off the bench for a bunch of
different teams i think he played like
12 years okay did tim legler start more
games
or play in more playoff games
both numbers are a bit low no offense
okay which means i'm offending you but
i'm saying no offense so i'm just tim
legler's going to be coming on am i are
we offending tim langley not you
you are but you know he has very
successful career okay so did tim legler
have more starts or playing more playoff
games right
i think he's talked about the playoff
series against the bulls and i think
that might be his only playoff
series you're correct three playoff
games okay he started four out of 310
games for his career oh so he had more
starts than playing did i mention that
he led the league in shooting percentage
twice yeah great as we bring in tim
legler from the mothership it's quite an
introduction there tim i'm gonna blame
paulie on that with i don't know why you
know we gotta skew mean-spirited today
but uh tim legler the former nba
sharpshooter espn nba analyst uh thanks
for joining us tim
it's always my pleasure i didn't know
it's kind of like a boxing match it was
like ding ding and then you came
charging across the ring at me going
haymakers you know let's feel each other
out a little bit let's dance a little
here you know no that's he that's
paulie's mean spirit no offense do you
remember your four starts
in europe none of them none of them
i don't i honestly do not remember
because they obviously i came off the
bench they were so infrequent no i could
not i have a pretty
a pretty solid memory i mean i could go
all the way back to high school games
and tell you how many points i scored in
games and everything else a lot of my
college and nba career i do not remember
those games paulie give me the uh four
starts of tim legler's nba career it was
all in his final season in the league
with golden state warriors he started
four games that year oh okay
that makes sense actually that makes
sense
we had we were really banged up i
remember i went there to play for pj
carlissimo
last year of my career and he got fired
right around christmas
and shortly thereafter i retired from
the nba
so it's a package deal that you and pj
were
gonna leave well well it didn't help
that i was uh didn't help that i was
still in my fourth year basically
recovering from just blowing my knee up
completely uh with three ligaments torn
at the same time at the end of the 95-96
season i played four more years and it
just it was too it never really
recovered and it was a grind and it wore
on me mentally and then
combined with the fact that i went all
the way out to san francisco to play for
pj and he was gone
i just had an epiphany one day driving
any practice arena i was done i couldn't
do it anymore i wasn't enjoying the
process of what i was going through
physically anymore it was overwhelming
me and it took away from the joy of the
game the most talented teammate you ever
played with
oh man physically gifted i would say
chris webber in his prime in washington
and i played with i don't even know how
many hall of famers i'd have to go and
look at all the teams i played on the
number of guys and i played with tom
chambers kevin johnson dan marley in
phoenix i played with uh jamal mashburn
in dallas jimmy jackson i played with
latrell spreewell chris mullen tim
hardaway in golden state i played with
weber juwon howard um at the top of the
list probably my time in washington
weber was the most physically gifted
player um
unfortunately with us he just had a hard
time staying healthy i wonder what
mahmoud abdul rauf would be like in
today's nba he you know we talk about
kyrie's handle
the best handle i had seen
previously
might have been his mahmood was
so quick that crossover you know he was
chris jackson in college when he played
with shaq but
mahmoud was uh he was he was quick man
and he was chris jackson with me when he
was a rookie when i was in denver and i
never saw a player stop on a dime shoot
the ball with with that quicker release
in my life and you could talk about some
of the great ones to do it for a smaller
guard
i never saw a guy get off the ground
quicker and get the ball out of his hand
other than chris jackson he was
absolutely unbelievable i'm wondering
about john morant tim that you know is
this sustainable
attacking the rim at that size now i
know that he's developed a little bit
more of an outside uh game you know
derek rose never developed that um but
you start to attack can you continue to
attack at that size or lack thereof with
john moran
that's a good point it's fair he's 175
pounds probably he you know every time
he goes down i think people hold their
breath the one thing
i will say about john moran um he's not
just always trying to overpower you by
dunking on you he's got he can he's got
uh incredible ability to finish with
either hand he's got great body control
he gets around guys he's got scoops
floaters runners with either hand at the
rim so he's starting to do a better job
of manipulating his body so he doesn't
take that full flat on contact into his
chest because you're 175 and you come in
from that height with that amount of
speed when you take off any contact
could send you flying he's doing a
better job of avoiding the big hits at
the rim then he actually reminds me of
three guys
um in kind of one body he he's got the
relentlessness of an ai that's kind of
what he reminds me of in that way he's
got the body control and finishing
ability with either hand of a kyrie
irving
and then he's got this explosive
athletic ability of a russell westbrook
it's like all in one body
um and you know he's he's right now is
the most entertaining player in the
league
yeah i'm there with you on it i just i i
get worried that when you're young you
know dwyane wade did this like you just
started to attack michael jordan did
this you would just attack you attack
you attack and then eventually you have
to have a little more well-rounded game
and and if he develops that jump shot
three-point shot
now you know you you've got to pick and
choose it's like giannis if janus starts
to nail those three pointers i mean it's
over you got to decide am i going to
guard you on the perimeter or i'm going
to back away i'm going to you know then
you're going to get to the hoop on me
but i think that's what i'm curious
about with john moran he's fun
but i i hope it's sustainable
yeah i think the one thing um he also
has going for him if you watch him on a
nightly basis he's he's got
an ability to make shots from that six
to ten foot range with with these push
shots he's mastered so again he has
other things to go to where it just
doesn't have to be finished at the rim
he can release the ball before that the
other thing he's got going for him let's
be honest it's not the same era you're
not getting laid out like you were
before i mean guys are not coming over
with the antenna doing damage when you
turn the corner on somebody and you're
the help defender you know used to be
you'd hit somebody in the chest when
they were up in the air you didn't
really care about what was about to
happen there was no replay no flagrant
nobody was getting tossed you just got
up you checked your fillings you lined
your spine you put cotton balls in your
nose and stop the bleeding and you shot
your two free throws now it's different
man there's replays from eight angles
guys are gonna lose a lot of money
everybody's watching they've created a
league that wants to accentuate
this raw athletic ability and so he does
also have that going for him he's born
in the right era to play this style what
is charles oakley saying when he says
that giannis would have to come off the
bench
in his era
i don't know you know listen man i'll be
doing this a long time dan this is my
21st year of being uh you know analyzing
the game and working in this industry
and i know sometimes i probably sound
the same way like you're just holding on
so bad to your era but that's one of
that's one of the craziest things i
think i've heard anybody from my era say
you know that's that's the ultimate get
off my yard you know statement
uh because i heard that and i was i i
actually had to go and kind of read that
a couple times to make sure that i was
understanding what he was saying it's
it's that's nuts and i think it speaks
directly to
guys from that era that played in the
80s or 90s particularly 90s like my
decadent charles
um
it's you have a difficult time
because of the lack of physicality in
the game and we talk about it an awful
lot i think charles that's really what
he's hung up on there he's tim legler
he's a former nba player espn nba
analyst i saw where kyle korver is
working with ben simmons
now you're a great shooter
i'm trying to figure out
what
where do you start with ben simmons
well the problem i think with ben
simmons is look there's a lot of guys
that can go teach you know proper
mechanics and all those things and and
focus on the right things i mean there's
no question so a lot of people qualify
to do that
problem is
how do you change someone's wiring
in their in their brain and i think ben
simmons biggest issue is between the
ears
and i don't know what he has ever done
to address that because i really believe
and i said this the next morning
on the air after that last loss against
atlanta that ben simmons needs to spend
a good portion of his offseason
dealing with a sports psychologist
because what i watched was not normal i
watched a guy with elite level athletic
ability
basically
um
refused to process obvious scoring
opportunities for himself and it wasn't
just that one play that we keep talking
about when he turns in the post he's got
a wide open dunk and he passed the
baltimore t style it's not just that
play that was the culmination that was
when everybody jumped on because it was
so obvious but if you watch that whole
series i mean five fourth quarters in a
seven game series your starting point
guard does not attempt a field goal
that tells you the guy's going out of
his way
to to process obvious scoring
opportunities for himself and that's a
lack of confidence
that's a guy that's dealing with
something that's interrupting the
natural flow of what his body wants to
do his muscle memory is shot and it's
between the ears so yeah mechanics yes
his elbow's out to the side his wrist
looks funky all of those things i've
seen guys weird mechanics make shots
it's he doesn't see what he's supposed
to see and have his body react to that
he avoids those situations and by the
way dan throughout this entire scenario
all this stuff that played out all
summer and into the fall and now he's
finally in brooklyn guess what
no one has talked about whether he's
addressed any of that so when he shows
up on the court in brooklyn
that little thing that issue i was
joking he put it in a carry-on bag and
he flew up to brooklyn when he got off
the plane he got to the hotel and he
opened that bag that little issue was
still in there it travels
and it's going to surface again because
he hasn't really addressed that and i
think it's honestly a psychological
issue with his confidence more than his
mechanics yeah that's well put
watching the sixers last night i know we
want to make them the new shaq and kobe
here
it feels like
that for me watching the sixers
that i'm i'm more curious about tyrese
maxie and tobias harris and and what
they will contribute when you get to the
playoffs because harden has this ability
to disappear
in the playoffs and we know embiid has
been great but i think if they're going
to win a championship i i want to know
who else is going to help them because i
thought the seth curry loss was a big
loss losing him to brooklyn but i you
know maxie i i love he's not afraid and
tobias harris still looking for sort of
his role there but those guys are really
important to me
uh what do you think it hinges on for
this team to win a championship there's
such a great point and this is why i'm
constantly butting heads with all my
knucklehead friends in philadelphia that
love this team and you're not even
allowed to be honest about issues
because dan the truth is i think all
three key guys
for the sixers have a lot to prove
because of moments they've had in the
postseason james hardy alluded to it
james harden has had some of the most
head-scratching moments
in a playoff series that were critical
like
series defining moments
and he turns into like a different
player
with his lack of aggressiveness it's
it's been mind-blowing and that to me
maybe that's pressure joel embiid did
not play well against toronto when they
got bounced the year toronto won it he
did not play well against boston the
year that they got bounced in the bubble
he's a guy that has a lot to prove now i
do think this he looks like a different
guy in terms of his
his conditioning everything so i'm not
worried about him but then doc rivers be
the third guy he's had more 3-1 series
blown leads than any coach in history so
they've got a lot to prove in the
postseason so you're 100 right where is
the help going to come from and right
now maxie
who i was worried about because he
looked so good this year and i was so
excited about his future he's like oh
man what do you know what's this guy
going to do now you bring in a guy like
james harden take the ball out of this
kid's hands
he's just a basketball player apparently
because he looks completely confident
just being an attacker he said that's
fine no problem he's got a smile on his
face a bounce in his step
and he is getting better every single
night it doesn't have to be both guys
it's just got to be
one of the two maxi or harris who is
going to be the guy that every night
you're getting you know on a bad night
you're getting 16
on a good night you're getting 25 and
it's every night who is that going to be
it looks like it's going to be maxie
because tobias harris has had a very
difficult time finding his rhythm
because they haven't given him those six
eight isos a game he was getting where
he gets into a rhythm he's not getting
that now he's more of a catch and shoot
guy a slasher now and he seems to be
affected by that whereas max he's just
like hey this is fun every time it
touches my hands i can just go attack i
don't have to worry about creating
offense for anybody and he seems like a
jordan clarkson jamal crawford type of
role right now which is suiting him very
well i'm contractually obligated to ask
you about the lakers the lakers play the
clippers coming up tonight
um
do you hold out hope that they can
actually be
are they a championship caliber team
when everybody's healthy are they just a
spoiler
no i think i think i'm past that point
now with them finally and i hear what
you're saying i mean
i'm the same i have to talk about them
every day
and it's amazing because it's just it's
one flat performance after another
it's a team that looks like to me has no
ability to overcome adversity in the
moment every time a run happens against
them
heads drop shoulders drop body language
stinks lack of effort getting back on
defense after turnover and then most
importantly when there's a time out
those guys go over to the bench take a
look at them they're not speaking to
each other
so to me
there's so many issues and anthony davis
as good as he is this is more than a
band-aid he's going to provide he's
going to have to be a tourniquet he's
got to come in there and he's got to
solve all of their issues and i just
think
you don't just go from what i've watched
all year
regardless of his talent to all of a
sudden now you're a team that's a
contender here's what i think they're
going to make the play in because they
have lebron james he'll make sure they
make the play-in and the teams trying to
catch them are not good enough so he'll
make the play in he could potentially
even get them out of the play-in maybe
they get into the eighth spot or the
seventh spot well you know what that
means
that means you get
phoenix golden state or memphis and i do
not think the lakers are beating any of
those three teams in a seven game series
paul do you want to apologize to legs
because i thought legs killed it yeah he
crushed the segment that was by far our
best guess segment of the day so far
that was a better performance than his
three playoff games that he had
went back there listen listen i i don't
need the sucking up now okay i'm gonna
go the first round's over i'm gonna go
you know cut me mick i'm gonna keep
fighting i'll fight another day i took
some shots right when the fight started
i wasn't ready i thought it was an
exhibition match you know
like hulk hogan and rocky you know hey
let's just have some fun here next thing
you know he's getting thrown out of the
ring okay that's kind of what it felt
like i'll be back though and i'll come
well armed
and if you want to come into my dojo and
we shoot some hoops here at my man cave
i mean you're you're more than welcome
the door is always open absolutely i
would absolutely love that i would love
that nothing nothing better than
shooting hoops with you dang i know
you've got a pretty good stroke
i don't know how often you shoot anymore
but listen i'll tell you this i i just
turned 55
when i turned 50
that morning all i wanted to do was with
my kids my wife i said what do you want
to do i said you know what i want to do
i want to go see how many shots it will
take me to make 53 pointers
and i went to the gym and my daughter
who played college basketball was
rebounding for me and my wife videotaped
it and i went 50 for 54
from the three-point line now i will say
this caveat it was college threes okay i
don't have i don't have that deep 25
foot range anymore man that's not fair
but they were college threes but i went
50 of 54 on my 50th birthday
yeah good for you
good for you
uh hey great to talk to you as always
thanks for the insights tim we
appreciate it anytime dan that's tim
lagler espn nba analyst